[Music]
we're talking with Melanie in Detroit
this is the Dave Ramsey show she had a
baby back in the fall as $24,000 in
credit card debt is not paid on it since
then $9,000 part net with a value of 15
husband makes 32 she's home with the
baby baby had a couple of difficulties
and so did mom and we're trying to work
through all that a lot of scary stuff
going on is that a fair summary of what
you told me so far yes that's a fair
share okay cool
now I'm curious how much credit card
debt did you have before the baby came
it was probably about 19 okay what you
spend the five on extras for the baby
after he was born
unfortunately so you impulse your butt
off in the middle of all these medical
things and that's some retail therapy
yeah baby's got some struggles so we're
going to buy baby a bunch of stuff he
doesn't even know exists pretty much
yeah
got it okay no no I don't blame you I
understand how it happens but we need to
say out loud what's going on because you
got to reverse these trends underneath
the debt to get rid of the debt does
that make sense to you yes can I ask
okay
we just found out that our furnace needs
to be replaced also okay good who said
that we had the electrical company and
the gas company come out here because we
were having issues with it and they're
saying that it's starting to show signs
of giving us carbon monoxide mm-hmm yeah
get a second get a second opinion that's
a scam half the time those guys say that
just because they want to sell your
heating air unit I've had that happen
three times in my life so um and I
hadn't died yet so I'm not saying you
don't need to inspect it but you didn't
to look at it because some of these guys
are drama queens I'm pitching new units
and you really can't afford one right
now so what's your home worth house is
worth about 160 and what do you owe on
it 49 okay in a chapter 13 you're gonna
struggle to be approved with that much
equity because the courts like for you
to pay your bills when you have that
much equity in your house now you can
file a thirteen probably because of your
low income all right and what's your
house payment 632 okay ha okay so here's
the formula I number one I put
bankruptcy in the same category as I do
divorce sometimes people go through it
and I still like them they're still my
friends I'm not mad at them but it's not
something I would wish on my worst enemy
because you think you've been through
stress we're getting ready to add stress
to it not take it away okay it's not
this great relief it's five years of
hell while you pay this lousy $24,000
back I'd rather figure out a way to pay
it back and you know since you're
already deeply in default on these
things really about all they can do is
sue you and they won't do that for about
two more years so I think your husband
picks up some extra jobs and you start
looking for some things you can do from
home for some income and let's add
$1,000 a month to this equation and
every so often when you save up a little
bit of money you call up the smallest
credit card and you settle with them and
so you got a $2,000 credit card and you
offer them a thousand bucks to settle it
you get it in writing and if you were to
settle this whole thing for 50 cents on
the dollar then it's $12,000 and do a
file bankruptcy on $12,000 is kind of
silly
right because that's why it's like pizza
driving away from getting it paid off so
he's he's pizza driver we didn't yeah
that's actually what I used to do for a
living so I mean you know what you can
make you make thousand fifteen hundred
bucks a month if you're working oh yeah
I made two grand a month now you go on
two grand a month changes your dadgum
life right now right two grand a month
means you're 100% debt free in about a
year okay that right there tells us
you're not bankrupt okay now I don't
want that for you but I didn't want any
of this for you you didn't want any of
this for you number one concern take
care of baby number two concern take
care of you number three concern you
take care of food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities and
then we're gonna play with these credit
cards okay okay they're there the bottom
of the list and we're gonna get to them
when we get to them we're not gonna
stress about them this is a Monopoly
game you're behind then but what happens
is you've had about six layers of stress
pile up and it'll it'll break the
camel's back that last straw you know
what I'm saying yep and you're like
running to the shelter of chapter 13 to
feel better not because necessarily the
math is leading you there does that make
any sense to you it makes complete sense
I got married to my husband I had filed
chapter 7 because I was young and dumb
so and it didn't fix anything here we
are again they didn't here we are again
so dad is never the problem it's the
symptom including what I did it to by
the way not just picking on you I don't
think it's always the symptom it's
always the symptom not the problem so we
want to dig this dandy line out by the
roots or they grow back and spread six
more dandelions so you got it yet fix
the whole situation go next time we're
in stress we're not gonna have any debt
and we're gonna have a big fat juicy
emergency fund and we're gonna control
ourselves next time we're in stress yes
and that's how you got here did I miss
something no anything I think you can do
this I really do and I I don't want to
take up too much of your time our
accounting has where if you let's say
you need something replaced in your
house to make your house livable they
have a program that is 0% interest loans
I think it's a lien on the house up to
$18,000 you don't have to pay it back
right away you can actually pay it back
when you sell your house if we need the
furnace do you think that that would be
an idea to do the first step of getting
out of that is to stop borrowing money I
know that answer your question yes okay
thanks for calling kiddo